i have mentioned this to someone before
when i talk about the show that it's a
lot like when a couple gets pregnant
and they say we are having a baby yeah
however one person is carrying that
child
we are having that baby michael every
day and you are carrying that child
[Music]
welcome to a very special episode of yes
or no this is a very special episode
because while we have had many
illustrious figures on this show before
never to my knowledge have we had
an actor a movie star someone who is in
the movie that is released nationally
right now courageous legacy this is the
follow-up to a movie that was released
in 2011 did extraordinarily well in a
good movie about faith about family
about fathers
a good movie about the police
and a movie
where one of the stars
is the producer of this very show not
just yes or no but the michael and also
here at the daily wire that would be
ben davies ben this is surreal this is
very strange you are usually
right there directing this show but now
you are in the hot seat it feels so
different being in this seat and not
knowing a single question that i'm about
to read really stresses me out but thank
you so much for having me michael first
of all you know it's truly an honor to
finally talk to you face to face this is
the first time we've ever spoken
without you know how a secretary sort of
running back and forth this is this is
really great because a lot of the people
who are watching don't know this but
we're such a powerful operation here at
the daily wire we're so leaning into
hollywood that even our producers are
movie stars
uh yeah i guess you could give me that
title except uh i don't think anyone
would know me walking through the office
like you're that guy that wrecks
michael's show every single day that's
usually how i'm known as i walk these
halls
but you know you really have had a long
career in film and this is a big movie
and it did extremely well 10 years ago
and now this new version where where
you've you've all aged obviously 10
years this this is now in theaters
nationwide yeah it was great to come
back and see how old everyone got after
10 years but it is great to see there
was such a great response from the first
movie that came out in 2011 with
courageous and then
the impact they had across the country
that sony actually came back and like
hey can we print some more money and
release this movie again
and uh they brought us all back to shoot
this alternate ending for courageous and
so we've all actually legitimately aged
10 years we shot the original in 2010 we
shot this alternate ending in 2020. they
re-cut the movie it's released
nationwide right now so everyone please
go out see it i'd really appreciate it
and i can't wait to see the response
hopefully it's just like it was in 2011.
this reminds me of that movie boyhood
you know where they shot it over a
period of time except this one exactly
what it felt like going back i was like
dude did you have our photos like when
we originally shot the movie like oh man
it's been rough on you and we came back
like seeing people aged 10 years but
this movie i assume does not have that
big lib patricia or cat in it this is
the most based movie that's going to
come out this is great okay well this is
obviously now it's got a leg up on
boyhood all right so i don't need to
explain the rules of this game to you no
you do not and i would like to let
everyone know that i did invent this
game and it hurt me personally every
time that you just disregarded the point
system just the flagrant disregard for
the care that i put into this game the
points don't matter so we actually did
do a new graphic so every time you get a
question wrong you're going to get
dinged for it and i'm gonna get a point
and at the end of this justice will be
served for all those times you
completely disregarded my rules fair
enough now you know look as you know i
don't i don't um pay a lot of attention
the rules should we start with a little
a little drink you're having a what what
is that an old-fashioned old-fashioned
all right chin chin
delicious
the only thing italians are good for is
pizza and gangster movies
it's ridiculous there's so many great
italians doing so many great things
we're also good at being gangsters
yeah secretly gangster movies come from
michael does run this place with an iron
fist like everyone is scared of what
they're going to find yeah no it's
michael it is really tough sometimes
like there was i don't know can we tell
tales at a school about personnel stuff
around so there was this guy we can
always cut out on post yeah okay because
there was this guy elliot ness one time
who worked who worked for this company
and he made a mistake you know and
sometimes you get written up at hr
you know maybe you i don't know you get
sent home or something
but this guy elliot ness
that's not how i reacted to him
i said i wanted this elliott nest dead
i wanted his family dead
i want his house to burn to the ground i
want to go to the ground i want to shut
his ashes
you know people don't know that because
it wasn't on camera you still got it
most people probably know you just from
the michael null show but michael
knowles is a very talented successful
gangster actor
mafioso so now we both got that right
we both we both get a point if we both
get a point of course you we have to you
drink yeah i think so yeah
okay
christian films are only entertaining to
people with morals
wow
i did not write that one
i agree with that but you know there's a
caveat here
all people have morals in the sense that
all people possess moral conscience all
people actually do know broadly the
difference between right and wrong
now some people don't act
in accordance with what they think is
right some people do the thing that is
wrong but they all know i mean this is
this is why we can you can watch a
christian movie you can watch some
bad movie you can watch whatever and you
can you actually can understand the
moral universe it's actually the only
way we have self-government is because
we know the difference between right and
wrong
it's a great answer it really is
but you are dead wrong michael
wow
okay uh
what most people don't realize when you
see a great movie and it lasts it's
because
at its core it's a christian movie like
the uh the writer of braveheart so this
is an explicitly christian movie i want
you to understand that when he was
interviewed with the 700 club yeah yeah
um there are christian movies that are
over the top cheesy and horrible
however not crazy it's not being one of
those it's
right but most movies that do last like
stand the test of time and you go back
and you watch and they're great yeah
yeah the the writer or director be like
this was intentionally a christian type
project and uh so not every movie
well i mean certainly christianity is
the greatest story ever told because it
is real and because it is it is the real
enactment of the deepest longings of our
hearts so i suppose all right i'll i'll
grant you that i i think we're quibbling
over i just want to score nature of
morals yeah i'm not i'm a little uh
suspect on the definition of morals here
but that's fine okay so then i drink
right because i lost exactly
the re-release of courageous removed
several scenes that had the character
david thompson
and the movie is better because of it
now i have to answer how you would
answer yeah
oh man
so i'm going to definitely get fired so
i'm not even wrote these questions but
i'm not going to answer the way that i
would answer i'm going to answer it the
way you would answer it correct
well
have you seen the first movie
not yet
but i am going to end up seeing it
before i see the second movie then
so you're going to say no because i
don't know for sure exactly okay
that's fair that is fair i can't make a
judgment about these things yeah um
here's the problem i have seen the first
one i have not seen the new cut so i
don't even know how to answer
and i don't know what scenes they may or
have added or removed so i think this is
just kind of a wash with the drink
because like i i do think that every
movie you know
over time you can go back and assess it
there are moments you thought were
precious and important that you have to
cut out there better so maybe it will
make the movie but i know this movie is
better than the original i don't know
how many of my scenes were cut this is
the problem it would be very funny if we
do this whole thing we plug this movie
and then they just completely cut your
character
i don't know how they would do it but
okay so i think we should probably drink
for that yeah
that's good okay
okay
uh the person sitting across from me is
easy to work with
so i got to answer for you yes okay
now
correct
you come out with it come out with it no
you don't you're you're flattering me
you're flattering me uh i send in my
script late i never get you the answers
to questions you need i barely respond
to any emails michael you've worked with
actors before that's true you know the
most difficult people on the planet are
actors
i think they are god's gift to this
world i i hate to brag too much since we
are like co-workers but even people come
in the office to like
get tours and i don't want to speak to
these people you're like oh bring them
in like i would love to have a chat and
like see how they're doing and get to
know people
and uh no other than you showing up late
every single day every single every
single day no matter what
other than that it's a breeze you're
right i'm basically mother teresa you're
right you're right so i got i got that
wrong take a sip
the other producers though are much more
difficult to work with
no that's that's without question
slight slight turn oh no i guess this is
sort of related to the movie police
reform is important
to moving forward in our country
police reform
police reforms this is the tricky
question
oh you know what yeah
so we're talking about like currently
what the police are doing yeah versus
what is this like the woke version of
reform or like the conservative version
of reform yes it could mean whatever it
could be so in the way it is commonly
understood let's say that in the way
police reform is commonly used or how
you would wish it to be reformed can i
do that like well that would be
different so we're going to do the
common tongue the common one i think we
i think we just answered
for the comment and then if we flipped
it we would just have to flip it right
yeah it's ridiculous it's so frustrating
to hear that we're going to fix the
problem by allowing more problems to
happen and
if it was my
jurisdiction it was my police force i
would want people throwing the can for
jaywalking and i guess what we'd live in
a better society i think because of it i
cannot stand like weakening our only
protection against the people that are
trying to wish people harm i mean you
know what i hear this too i hear this
often
pardon from our uh libertarian friends
out there they'll say you know
we have a big problem of over
incarceration in this country over and i
think okay well
crime is spiking right now right we got
a huge drug problem we got murders are
spiking all sorts it
would seem to me
that we have an under incarceration
problem in this country is that it
should again in the 90s always cite the
incarceration of people and with the war
on drugs or whatever but you also saw a
dramatic drop in crime yeah all of a
sudden like all magically when there was
people thrown in jail for crimes there
was less crime i know there was a new
york times headline it said something to
the effect of prisons keep filling
despite the crime rate dropping
well do you know what despite means it's
it's so perfect yeah so i think if you
and i could reform the police it would
be we want to enforce the laws and also
if you lock up granny for not wearing a
mask then that person should be thrown
and jealous that's the thing because
right now the cops are really good at
throwing up the viking guy from the
capitol they're really good at throwing
him in has anyone seen that guy by the
way
yeah he's in guantanamo it might be a
fed i don't know i'm kind of torn is he
a political uh prisoner or is he a fed
i'm not so sure so they they do that for
all the awful terrible maga people who
had the insurrection you know but
meanwhile the libs who burned the
country down for six months who like at
burned down courthouses police stations
private businesses killed dozens of
people
they go scot-free
i would like to reform our system such
that uh those guys don't go scot-free
and maybe you know granny from the
capitol doesn't get the book thrown at
her
i couldn't agree more all right you both
win that one it's me
let's see
oh
this is a good one this is probably my
favorite one so far um i got into i got
into political news because i couldn't
quite hack it as an actor hmm
and there's an old saying about this too
yeah yeah
however you gotta answer for me i got a
massive video both in political news
yeah but you're in a movie that just
came out hmm it's alright someone said
no
you're actually right because a lot of
people don't know this but i was in
politics first
i did not know that i was yeah my first
political i mean i'm saying
professionally obviously although frank
you know i did my first little play when
i was a kid at age eight but i did my
first campaign at age six because i
campaigned for bob dole in my first
grade classroom but uh no i my first
professional
uh campaign i was 18 or 19 and i'm
trying to think my first really
professional acting job i was probably
more like 22 or 23. so a long love i i
think the two are actually extremely
related and frankly my politics did did
have some effect on my uh meanderings in
hollywood as has happened to people
before but i think the two are really
related the way that you'll hear that
politicians and actors are the same is
that they're uh extremely um egotistical
liars both of them dare you
but and you know at their worst that's
true but i actually think the thing that
unites politics and show business and
actually why there's a huge
overlap between the two reagan
stuart smalley from saturday night live
arnold schwarzenegger jesse ventura
sonny boner at the list goes on and on
and on donald trump for that matter
is you have to
be concerned with the truth as an actor
the truth of your given circumstances
and as a politician you know sort of
deeper philosophical or theological or
political truths and then i think you
have to like people i mean you can speak
more to this but if you're an actor
you've gotta
your your job is to create characters
that are empathetic and uh if you're a
politician you just spend your whole
life at the vfw hall eating spaghetti
dinners with people so if you don't if
you don't like people there there's a
much easier way to make a buck than than
to do that i'm not even sure how to
answer this one i did start into acting
much earlier than you did i was two
years old when i did my first campaign
and then did commercials and your first
acting campaign you mean like that was
actually that was a print ad but then
the
the acting stuff really kicked off uh
high school
college and then i have been a leader
supporting in 25 different films even
before i did started working at the
daily wire
however i did
also because of
uh
just the the drying up of the market in
la i did actually seek out other
opportunities to do political commentary
actually started with rebel media
because i had so much downtime because
they were not they were literally not
casting any straight white men in
hollywood there were a bunch of articles
written on this too at the time so the
castle just dried up to nothing and then
you know a year of that i'm like well
i've got family and to provide for so
i'm going to get into politics so i but
i'm still doing acting so i guess but i
maybe i did because i couldn't hack in
hollywood i have no idea like i don't
know that's right i guess you could both
be a successful actor and have gotten
into political media so
that's true okay so it's uh would that
be a judgment call on your part then
because i'm not exactly sure i'm going
to keep my point but i am going to take
a sip okay i mostly
[Music]
okay
all right
protestants hate catholics because they
are simply jealous that they are not the
og christian religion
protestants hate catholics because
because they're upset that they're not
the og christian religion i'm going to
say i've got to answer for you that's
[Music]
so this is you could dispute the idea
that protestants hate catholics but but
let's say given that premise protestants
say catholics like in that world if
protestants hate catholics it is because
they're not the og christian religion
what would you say i would say uh yes no
i would say no
see that protestants don't hate
catholics because
well it's even more complicated than
that i'm saying if protestants do hate
catholics it is not because they the
protestants are not the og christian
religion
i think the reason that protestants if
protestants hate catholics or if they
you know have big problems with
catholicism i think it's because of
their own misunderstanding of
catholicism i i forget who put it this
way it was
some old theologian type one of those
guys one of those guys uh who was it
john henry newman or ronald knox or i
don't know is they all sound the same
yeah it was one of these guys who said
uh
it was fulton sheen anyway
that just go through the rolodex yeah
yeah was it saint augustine was it saint
thomas aquinas uh there are
not a hundred people in this country who
disagree with the christian faith there
are a million people or many more
millions of people who disagree with
their misperception of the of the
catholic faith but there are not a
hundred people who actually do and so
you'll hear these things a lot of my
protestant friends will say why do they
i mean we've had these discussions
before yeah why do catholics worship
mary you say well we don't worship mary
why do catholics pray to idols well we
don't pray to idols well why do you know
and i just think i if if those things
were true i would understand why
protestants would have a big problem
with catholicism problem is they're not
true well we're not going to settle our
differences over a drinking game
unfortunately but i do think you're all
right for me i don't think that
protestants hate catholic because they
think they're the og religion yeah um am
i correct on you no
no i think that uh protestants hate
catholics because they hate the truth
hey come on no i'm just i'm am i
okay so now do we i guess we both drink
on that uh yeah i believe so all right
usually the default is you just drink
you just drink that is one of the rules
that actually was one of the red ones
all right now you read the last one is
it my turn i believe so you know i you
read the religion i did read the last
one yeah
i would rather be stuck in an elevator
with ben shapiro than matt walsh
you uh
oh come on michael you know me better
than this
because you hate jews
[Laughter]
i thought the catholics hated the jews
yeah yeah hold on
i i would like to hang out with matt
walsh uh ben is just too he's he's so
much more intelligent than me that i
feel like i couldn't have a conversation
the only thing i would do is take a
selfie and ruin half my friendship
because they know that i'm friends with
this nazi jew that is just trying to
destroy the world
white supremacist
yes no it is it is tough to keep up with
ben too because bit you know the thing
that
ben does is he's doing like four things
at once all the time so you'd be having
a conversation but he is writing a
column you know in his as you're so it's
you're getting both but the another
person i've heard does that is jay leno
really i have just i don't know i don't
have firsthand experience but yeah i
think that's fair whereas walsh you know
the only thing he would do to distract
would be like chop down a tree or
something or you know he's such a bro
like the first time i actually hung out
with matt walsh we were at uh john
rich's party and walsh and i kicked up a
conversation we're smoking these
unbelievable cigars from the best cigars
i've ever had and then had whiskey and
talked like two hours such a good dude
and he plays
i've gotten like 10 words at a wall
she's got two hours what's wrong with me
man i don't okay
we both got it right so we both got it
right so we should probably drink
okay to you michael
film sets are a great place to spend
hours of your life
uh let's see because you're still in the
business so uh
i guess because i know this about you
i know you hate being on film sets i
hate it i mean why do you made
a great environment you know the last
gig i did before i hung up my spurs i
got to have a lead role in a movie and
uh i i'd never had a lead role in a
movie i'd had some supporting things and
all that and i'd done a lot of theater
and but i i thought okay now i'm gonna
and it's so
boring and it's so cause you just you
sit there i mean you sit there for hours
and hours and hours you do nothing no
one's even reading you're just kind of
making small cha touch small
talk and chit chat how many of those
have i had you do all of that and the
other thing that's
technically very hard about this is with
a play it's linear so you you work on
your sort of character arc
in a very direct way or with a movie you
might you might film the last scene
first and then the middle scene next and
then i hate plays so much because of
this i've never done plays in my life
like legitimately i've done 25 films
never done a play
and there's something so pure about
being in the moment you like dive into
these scenes i think it was i
describing the film citizen people i was
talking about my history in track and
field which that was what i did before
acting i was a the actual national
record holder in the decathlon
university of florida and i was the best
american ever at the time going into and
i got hurt and got in the film yeah yeah
but i know i got injured in my deck
athlete
too this is really how we bonnie was
talking about talking about uh you know
the swimming or whatever yeah but uh no
it's just it i'd describe it as just
each event you have to go on to the next
one and it's the most important event of
your entire life when the gun goes off
you just go and so every time i'm in an
acting scene with somebody i love
digging into the dramatic broken moments
of these movies and getting to
experience that and you're with people
that are like in the trenches with you
and when you're working with a good
director then they trying to capitalize
on what you're doing and you collaborate
it's this beautiful piece of art every
single time that i love and i i can't
get that experience as much as i like to
think that us doing the show every day
is that much fun it's just not quite
it's a very intense experience being on
a movie set yeah it because it's like
summer camp i mean you fall in love with
people you form cliques you you know you
think you're all gonna be friends
forever and then you never talk after
the movie in some cases and whereas with
a play it's much more like a real job
you show up every night or whatever you
know four nights a week and you you uh
yeah it's much less intense it's much
less intense for sure and i guess it's a
good question too if because we haven't
i don't know if any of these questions
are going to queue this up but because
it is such an intense experience i know
there's a debate about should you be
intimate on camera with someone that's
other than your wife and now you are
married and an actor or you have that
i'm not hung on my speech do you agree
that that is something that you would
should encourage as far as like because
you know it's not reality however you're
still doing some type of act which would
be also interesting yeah i'm really torn
because my uh
acting training such as it is was very
much from this the school of the
subconscious
you know the people like wynn handman uh
stella adler
sanford meisner's handmaid's teacher it
all comes from the group theater and the
group theater comes from
uh you know was influenced by russia by
stanislavski and stanislavski was
influenced
it's all freud basically it's all this
idea that in
pre-sort of you know technical or method
acting as it's sometimes called these
terms are a little um
imprecise it's not more annoying than a
method actor by the way but but it you
know there are so many different
versions of it yeah the thing that
unites all of these ideas is this idea
that instead of you know i'm in the
scene and i'm gonna be angry at this
person and so i'm going to do the things
that would make me appear so i'm angry
at this person
the subconscious organic acting is this
idea that i am going to push the buttons
in my subconscious such that like a
sponge filling with water it just sort
of pours out in this very organic way
but the thing that's dangerous about it
and i've come to appreciate this more
and more since i've stopped and given it
up especially since i've gotten married
is the whole point of it is
you really are in love with the person
you really are in in this very
you know yelling at them or having sex
with them or something
you're really that's a different yeah
but you're i'm not saying you're doing a
porno i just mean like even what
simulator you're kissing somebody
the whole idea of the organic acting is
it's it's real it really is real to you
and so then it will be real to the
audience and that to me seems
problematic yeah
i think it very well could be i mean
putting the porn aside obviously that
yeah i haven't done that since i left uh
chatsworth you know
it's like a town in the valley it is
it's hard to describe to people that
have not been in film like people think
of the notebook every single time like
how could you kiss this person and be so
you know it would be betray the person
that you that you're married to
and
like that trust and that level of
commitment and that emotion
but when you're in those scenes you you
haven't thought about the eight hour day
the ten people around you screaming
going back to one cutting microphone it
is so
removed from what you see in that
perfectly formed frame
that uh i mean if i came up and touched
your face it'd be different than if i
touch your face intimately michael and
so it's it to me it is it is a great
conversation i love having those with
different actors i have a lot of
christian friends that do not kiss on
camera people will see in a movie coming
up but i do but yeah kirk cameron who's
a good friend of ours he's a good person
and you're you're just a dude
apparently yeah
it does it does uh to me it feels very
different and it's a conversation you do
also have your spouse this is a you know
it's you're together in this i just
can't believe every time we've kissed on
camera it's not real for you that's what
i'm upset about
it was real for me michael
i would be okay with allowing girls to
compete in men's sports just to show the
absurdity of the notion that is or you
know for example uh letting sarah fuller
get totally rocked if she ever if she
had ever dropped the ball i don't know
with that reference
i know this reference i know who wrote
this question so we should let women
compete in men's sports so we can just
just absolutely how crazy it is then we
feel bad for the women it's like how
would you dare put this one in the
situation okay
no
no way you wouldn't put the women in
that situation just to show them the
wrong oh wait this is this whole thing
of like let's elect bernie just to show
everyone how bad it is like no it's my
country damn it and it's just wrong we
did do we did a very similar question to
this i believe with you and will whit
yeah and uh it was i i no i was wrong
too okay i think we should because i
for example like do you agree with like
that you should be able to discipline
your child like spanking biblically
speaking yeah i mean within within
reason yeah exactly within reason i
think there is no better cure for
insanity than reality and for you to get
what's coming
you don't touch a flame because you've
been burned before and as soon as you if
you remove if you keep people in a
bubble you keep your child in the bubble
they will never learn reality same thing
if you they may get a physical reaction
to burning but if you let your son talk
to your wife that way right like he
needs to know that that is not okay yeah
and i think it's so great for these
states to go down this road and let
people get absolutely rocked so reality
will reassert a lot of these women don't
want to compete against men i mean
some do and some are willing to do it
and they get their heads cracked open
because of it but i just think it's i
think it is just simply wrong to fight a
woman for instance and like punch a
woman and so i i just don't even if it
will i grant your point it'll teach the
lesson i still don't want to do it i
grant your point too but there is
something about having reality because
you and i can talk all day yeah there is
something that is just undeniable that
people can experience and that is one of
those things but why don't sarah fuller
tries to tackle somebody yeah is there a
fuller kicker at vanderbilt down oh yeah
oh absolutely came to the white house
they lost the game yeah yeah they lost
every game
it's gonna take a long time to recover
from that publicity stunt they did but
uh yeah i i think i i hear your point we
talked about this before but i think
reality is the only way to break through
to these people it's like that is the
red pill moment but what if
what if instead of merely having to
persuade them and get their ascent for
what if we just impose our will which
happens to be correct in this case
you're saying maybe we don't have the
political ability to do it i don't think
and i don't think it would change their
mind they would just say that you're
wrong and you're a better bigot which
maybe you are a bigot but it's just like
you know on this question
yes
punching women is bad i'm not opening my
mind on that so i yeah i think i got
that one right
yes and i got it so i got it
i had a great high school experience and
am in no way compensating by chasing
fame
all right uh how long do we have
yeah i had a great high school
experience yeah i think i'm sure you did
yeah man i was i was like no really
no it was horrible hold on so this is
why this question's being brought up
like i had a great time i you know i was
like classical i'm sure you didn't know
perfect sat twice you know good looking
guy in college
but hold on you're
you're you're good looking guy i don't
want this to get weird okay but you're a
good-looking guy you know obviously
talented athlete a talented actor
yeah i figured you'd be like you know
swoon all the honeys up on lover's point
what do you mean you had a bad time in
high school i went to a really wealthy
great christian private school and
everyone was good looking athletic
michael and i was homeschooled until i
was in eighth grade went to high school
didn't know any had no social skills as
far as how to interact with people that
weren't just being like perfect
homeschool
people
have ever been to a steady hawkins dance
before yeah i i i think once we did it
in my school where the the women asked
them that i was never asked to one and
then in high school you get asked a
jersey to wear at the different football
games like the women will ask like a
jersey to wear i had a total of three
girls ever asked me to wear the jersey
in the entire four years and i still
remember their names because i
appreciated it so much because you know
when at my own high school it was a very
very difficult experience and it was a
high school down the road actually from
here i bet those ladies are regretting
it now you missed out on this hunk
ladies this hunk movie star wow that's
crazy all right i'll drink so now you're
up yeah
i title the michael knowles videos for
youtube to be as clickbait as possible
so now i'm answering because i don't
title them right that was an answering
question the person who titles them does
it to be as clicky as possible
uh without question yeah that's an idea
that is the first thing i think about
every time i see those videos it's like
i don't care what michael said how am i
going to it's funny because often you
know i i i don't mean this uh i don't i
don't mean to disparage my own delivery
but i find my delivery on these videos
is sometimes it's a little more
circumspect it's a little well you know
there's this side and this side whatever
you can just say more intelligent than
this no no i'm not saying i'm saying
it's a little it's a little dryer though
and then i look at the title it's like
trans lesbian from pakistan and i think
wow man i gotta click on that that's
pretty interesting
all right so then yeah so we got that
one right but yeah cheers to clicks
okay
at this point the trans agenda only
exists to enrich big pharma by taking
advantage of the mentally ill by locking
them into lifetime prescriptions and
unnecessary surgeries despite the fact
that they will only be at best accrued
mockery of god's
[Laughter]
did i perfection this oh my gosh uh oh i
got to continue though due to youtube
and facebook rules make your guess and
do not verbally confirm if the other
person guessed correctly give only a
nonverbal confirmation okay so please
sum that up for me i'm going to sum it
up
in a slightly less outrageous way
powerful interests are exploiting
sexually confused people
to enrich themselves and to advance
their own view goals but not to help
these confused people
well when you put it that way michael
i still think you can't we can't affirm
or deny of course not
okay
all right uh you're up
this is gonna be interesting actually
i am more based than the person sitting
across from me
um the question is like by your
definition yeah yeah so i'm answering
how you would answer about it i would
say
yes yeah yeah i think
my answer for why this cannot be is
because i'm catholic it gets back to the
early because i'm catholic because i
don't believe in like you know like my
liberalism or whatever you know which i
i do think
the sort of non-eastern orthodox
non-catholic christians inevitably sort
of partake of that modern thing
uh but and you think because uh because
because i would lock up catholics
yeah yeah if you would agree with that
then and it's like because sometimes i
won't even admit they're turning the
freaking frogs guys
if they're not they're turning them
trans that is exactly right yeah you
know okay
i'm up
i could produce this show totally on my
own
well i can
i definitely can answer for you well
well no
chance no but yeah i i think i actually
have done this basically before i can
barely get from the makeup room into the
studio
i need it and i'm never on time but
certainly never on time yes so that was
obviously correct all right
if you're a man who is unmarried by the
by the time you're 30 it's because
you're selfish
why did you say no because i think you
believe that certain people will be on
different paths and it's not necessarily
selfish if they're following god's plan
yes and specifically
you know priests right i pray they don't
get married generally speaking they
don't get married and you're absolutely
right they're degenerates they're not
married by 30. so like
which is my baseness coming out yeah
every person i know that is not buried
by 30 and you know who you are it's
because you're selfish like that that's
what it is wow that's really
man
disregarding priestly celibacy to own
the trads okay that's fine that's fine
morally based movies that's funny do we
mean based or like based yeah morally
based movies are gaining in popularity
because people are craving traditional
value since the woke mob has diluted the
entertainment industry
well you
um i'm going to give like a very
esoteric answer i know i'm kind of like
well probably the exact same thing
yeah i think i mean it's like all movies
we're all partaking of the moral
universe and to your point like
braveheart is one of the greatest
christian films ever made so uh yeah i
think that's fair they're still not
flocking to these movies and there's
such a
like uh vice grip on the films they get
out there there's still going to be
these woke things that people are
flocking towards because that's where
all the advertising money is no one even
knows i had a movie came out in 2016
that i loved
not even people in the church knew about
it because dna was so low so no i think
that's still i think you're right i
think you're right you'd be optimistic
to say otherwise all right
having a day job means you haven't
really made it as an actor
oh having a day job in general well i
guess
no
no absolutely i mean i know you got a
point yeah yeah no i finally got no i
i know very successful actors who have
been in very very big movies whose faces
you would know who still do catering
gigs every now and again or tutor or
whatever because
you know you do like you can do a big
movie but you might only work once or
twice the year i mean it's just as a
matter of time it's like 15 bucks an
hour is going to support your family
sometimes you need that 15 bucks an hour
i mean i think was it
ryan what's his face ryan gosling didn't
he go back and work at fast food after
he made some big movie i mean it was you
know because he hadn't quite
hit his stride again yet
yeah
you are right about the time people
often do different endeavors like ashton
kutcher will you know work with uh uber
or whatever
however i think it by definition of you
making it it's like these are just kind
of toys that you're playing with it's
not like if you're an i feel like you're
a working actor a real successful actor
and you don't have to you're doing this
for fun
yeah so yeah but
i'll i'll give it to you on that like
that's yeah to really make yeah i guess
you know there's making it and then
there's yeah yeah he's making it and
then there's like brad pitt
yeah okay
oh we're getting right to the bottom
here last two i do more work for this
show than the person sitting across from
me
well
i'm not going to be offended michael
this is
tricky this is here's why it's tricky
i would say you do more things
for this show than i do for both this
this show obviously and for my show i
think you do more things for it but i'm
i'm thinking about it all the time
i'm writing all the time i'm i'm stewing
i'm traveling i'm trying trying my
darndest to own every single live that
goes before me every slight interaction
every invitation i all of it is oriented
toward one thing
you
so i would say it's very difficult to
quantify that and trying to outbase me
yeah i know certainly yeah yeah uh so
now well i would say i do spend a lot of
time stressing about this show you do
and thinking of how am i going to title
this to be clicky enough for people to
pay attention to michael knowles yes no
you're what should i put in the
thumbnail every single day who is
messing up on our set that i have to
fire or tell to do something better yeah
there's a lot of things i'm worried
about you're right you're right however
i have mentioned this to someone before
when i talked about the show that it's a
lot like when a couple gets pregnant
and they say we are having a baby yeah
however
one person is carrying that child
we are having that baby michael every
day and you are carrying that child yeah
actually yeah no you are i will say that
yes you are carrying that child and i'm
the husband being like i'm happy i'm a
part of this too baby i'm trans and
you're my sugar daddy people don't know
this about the show because it seems so
a lot of time we try to make it casual
on purpose so it's relatable however you
are in that room writing yeah furious
and working slaving away for you
like in the salt mines i know you almost
feel bad to come in there and like talk
to you about why catholics are wrong but
it's like i have to joke
all right you're reading the last
question ryan i'm reading the glasgow
okay here we go
since when you're in the end and i
didn't even get close to the end of mine
yeah yeah
all right catch up
[Laughter]
bing
this is like such
a stupid question
being tall and attractive has helped my
career
well
by whose definition is the problem let's
see i would i would say well for you yes
and then let's see what you're uh
well wow
see what you don't understand mr davies
you were you six three six four give or
take yeah okay so what you don't
understand because you say michael
you're not six three you're a little
you're a little uh less tall than six
63.
so your conclusion of that is that i am
not tall but you see these things are a
little bit relative because compared to
the italian peoples compared to the
people in new york
i am shaquille o'neal i am a giant
actually there's a photo i went to italy
once i was 15. so i was still growing
and i took a photo with these two guys
you know just kind of average italian
guys they went up to my like chest and
these but
yet if i were to go to whatever
scandinavian you know
viking yard that your people come from
they would they could stomp me probably
down so i think uh relatively i i'm
gonna have to move this to a yes
okay um
i think you lean into the intelligence
michael
and uh
i think that is where your real real
gift is well the uh the scandinavian
people i think on average are six one
yeah like the average height so you're
right there this is why it is very
different than the italians apparently
which are allegedly pygmy people
according to you i had no idea
it was tough in the boot for a while you
know i i found out that i did an
ancestry sort of thing you know my my
dna and i found out i am part swedish i
thought i don't look as hard as that
yeah i thought it was a small part
something tells me
some uh some one of your ancestors
went marauding some coast of britain or
or perhaps even italy and maybe had a
little fun with some of the locals there
and that might that might be the result
that explains this yeah that explains
that explains this
uh ben the movie's out now yes people
can see it people are seeing it they can
see you now often they can't see you
often you're buying the camera they're
seeing you right now
and you should see me in theaters and
and we should all go see ben
in theaters go check it out courageous
legacy
chin chin
[Music]
[Music]
you